let's bring in CNN military analyst retired
U.S army General Wesley Clark as well as CNN
contributor on Russian Affairs Jill Daugherty
General Clark first on these major developments
today when it comes to tanks how big of a game
changer potentially could be the German Leopard
tank and eventually the U.S Abrams Tanks how
big of a change could that be on the battlefield
well I think it's a very significant politically
wolf it depends on how many tanks actually get
to the battlefield and what Ukraine does with
them uh General's illusion he says he needs
300 to 500 new tanks so I'm hearing he may get
a hundred combination of Abrams and leopards
sure it's good in case of a breakthrough
or it shuts up an armor Brigade to punch
into the South but Ukraine still needs the Deep
attack systems it needs the long-range drones or
eight takims really would help to have aircraft
and they've got to hold on the Eastern Front
good point you know Jill what message does this
send when it comes to tanks what message does
it send to Putin and how do you expect
Russia May respond they were issuing all
sorts of warnings if you start sending tanks
to Ukraine this could be a game changer from
their perspective they would see the U.S or
Germany being part of the Ukrainian offensive
you know welfare already saying they've been
saying it since this issue came up that this
would be playing by fire that the West would
be risking uh expanding the war risking a
confrontation between NATO and Russia I
mean the Russians are throwing as many
red flags up as they can and I think because
they are worried because these maybe they're
not complete Game Changers but the Russian tanks
are not adequate to go up against NATO tanks and
so I they're worried they're saying these would
be legitimate targets and uh and again that it
would hurt relations specifically with Germany
but I think they're worried we shall see our
general Clark all this comes as the U.S is now
urging Ukraine to cut its losses around Bahamut
and focus instead on planning an offensive in
the South what do you make of that strategy
I think it would be helpful if it's possible to
do that but on the other hand you've got to be a
little careful giving up ground in the East that's
really tactical decisions it's Creek line or river
line by River Line it's Village it's looking
at lines of communication and Road networks
um yes we need an offensive in the South there's
no doubt about it critical terrain is cutting off
the land bridge into Crimea and that would be the
intent and the idea would be that if we could get
into maneuver Warfare we wouldn't have to match
the Russian's artillery tube or artillery shell
for artillery shells but to do that you cannot
give up the Eastern Area you've got to find a
way to hold it can you get more advantageous
positions and you can shorten the lines a
little bit maybe but uh this is a tough call of
the ukrainians they don't want to give up their
territory it's their country so what they want is
the whole left and punch yourself to do that they
need more tanks they need long range bars and they
need the logistics to keep it all on the battle it
looks like they're about to start getting all
that all right retired General Wesley Clark
Jill Doherty guys thank you very very much let's
continue the discussion right now with Democratic
Senator Richard Blumenthal of Connecticut he's a
key member of the armed services committee I know
you're just back senator from this bipartisan
delegation you were on you went to Kiev you bet
there with President zielinski how significant
is this apparent breakthrough right now for the
U.S and the Allies to start providing Abrams and
leopard battle tanks to Ukraine it is profoundly
significant wolf we heard again and again not only
from president zielinski but from his top military
leaders that these tanks remember the Firepower
the armor they have the mobility are essential
to defending against the onslaught the Russian
offensive that is anticipated not months from
now but literally weeks away and one of the key
military leaders said to me why don't you trust us
in effect saying we have used what you've given us
to such great effect they push them away from Kiev
the Russians they have made major progress in the
East now the conflict is deadlocked and ukrainians
want to mount their own counter offensive and
the tanks are essential but here's the key point
wealth time is of the essence time is not on their
side so they need these tanks literally tomorrow
not months from now training transport need to
be compressed because you you keep pointing out
Senator this is a in your words a critical turning
point in the war that we're seeing right now what
will it take in the upcoming spring fighting to
convince Putin he simply can't win in Ukraine
what it will take is Success on the ground
and an offensive that puts in play Crimea and
points close to the Border with Russia so that
Putin feels the heat of their military prowess
the tanks are important as a message to Putin
that he's not going to fracture or divide the
Allies as has been part of his goal all along and
you're absolutely right the war is at a critical
Turning Point a time of Maximum danger but also
major opportunity and I can't emphasize strongly
enough how important time is and there's a larger
lesson here wolf that I would say we all ought to
take from this experience we have provided what
is needed when the ukrainians have requested but
often only after delay the heimar artillery the
Patriot missile defense some of the other arms
we need to take the lesson to say yes that ought
to be the default yes until we find a persuasive
reason to say no because the delay often takes
a toll in Blood and lives on the battlefield